Baker how are you I'm doing great how
are you I'm doing okay how did you find
out when Bob Stoops announced he was
stepping down who actually from a group
text of friends back home I was at my
house and got a couple text messages
asking what's going on up in Norman I
had no clue so in a couple text messages
later they sent a screen shot of
somebody releasing the news on Twitter
so then I had text messages from the
team saying that our meeting got moved
up so I said I knew but and so we got a
call from Coach Riley saying to come in
and talk to him and coach stoops and I
heard from Coach Stoops in person before
he addressed the team so it was a little
bit you know a little bit of a
rollercoaster day did you feel bad
though angry that Coach didn't call you
to tell you this that you're hearing it
from other people no not at all
you know because he it there are so many
things that he had to do you know
because he's he's telling people the
history tire or he's gonna retire and he
wants to make sure the coach Riley's
gonna be a coach I couldn't even tell
you how many lists of approval it has to
go through so he's got to tell people
and eventually it'll get leave so it's
no surprise that it got out early are
you interested in this Floyd Mayweather
Conor McGregor fling you know I'm gonna
watch it I'm interested but I don't know
what to think of it are you interested
in boxing or MMA yeah I'm gonna pull
from McGregor on this one why
everybody's thinking Floyd you know you
got to root for the underdog he's
undefeated
you got it root for Berger got a pull
for him it's not even his sport so you'd
like to see him when he said Baker
Mayfield the Oklahoma quarterback you
guys come in ranked 7th in the preseason
I I was curious about the numbers you
put up the quarterbacks that went in the
draft why you didn't declare to go to
the NFL I'm sure and winning a national
title is one thing but you have to look
at your bigger future here why didn't
you go pro this past year
that really is the reason I wanted to
win a national title you know is that's
when I was fighting for eligibility it
you know it was it was a long process
because I truly wanted to play it
Oklahoma it would be a dream come true
so and win a national title would be the
biggest one so that's the biggest reason
yeah look at myself compared to other
guys that left and I have all the
confidence in the world about my
abilities but you know I did a lot of
unfinished business here but do you
think you're every bit the quarterback
mahomes is I think you know he's
obviously very talented a special player
I just think we have a different tool
said I think we're able to do different
things well but yeah I I truly do
believe in my ability yeah but it is did
you read the scouts what they thought of
you your draft profile
I did not how could you not read your
draft profile you would because I can
probably tell you what this is okay
sorry McLovin
let let Baker tell us and then you can
tell him if he's on to what they were
talking about all right give me your
draft profile in your own words Baker
what what you think they said about you
okay under sized isn't comfortable in
the pocket enough doesn't have strong
enough arm we'll see how he plays
without his playmakers that he lost okay
McLovin how did Baker do as an NFL scout
I he what the column I'm reading has
pros and cons and he did get some of the
cons okay but he missed a lot of the
pros to be fair give me a couple pros on
eyes very difficult player to defend his
best trade his ability to escape and
extend plays if his first and second
reads aren't available he runs around
behind the line of scrimmage allowing
his past catches plenty of time to
uncover he has the ability to drive the
ball he's ultra competitive he pops
right up after taking some huge hits now
you know what I see Baker when I watch
you play is a little bit more Russell
Wilson than
Johnny Manziel and Johnny Manziel was
mentioned in one of these draft profiles
of you that you try to improvise and you
can't do that in the NFL who do you try
to model your game after who that's not
a question I think it's kind of a mix I
think the passion for the game and love
for the game I'd say it would be Brett
Favre and then you know between Russell
Wilson and Drew Brees just how's the
students of the game and how they play
the chip on their shoulder and they just
command their team they do it I mean at
a high high level and so I think it's a
mix of a few guys that I'd like to say
that I can model my game after you were
voted the biggest trash talker in the
big 12 yes I also got one vote for the
nicest player in the big 12 did you vote
for yourself is the biggest tranch
talker in the big 12 I voted for Orlando
Brown my left tackle what do you say
during a game anything that comes to
mind I mean it could be anything that I
mean it could just be completely
irrelevant it might be somebody that
I've that I know or that I've played
against for a couple years now so I mean
it could be anything but but normally a
quarterback doesn't want to rile up the
defense
I can I can read people well and so I I
try to do that with my own players and
see how they react and how they handle
certain things you know you think about
it if if you're under their skin and
they're not focusing on doing their job
and I'm already winning so it's one of
those things it kind of reminds me of
christian Laettner when he was a Duke he
wanted to get under your skin I don't
think there's got to be a 3430 I hate
Baker Mayfield at least not yet if you
win if you win a nationalist stillwater
they might have a 30 for 30 I hate Baker
Mayfield her some of the other cities
there but if you win a national title
maybe they'd have a 30 for 30 on you
okay
Justin Timberlake fan is that right
huge Justin Timberlake fan have you
I have not that would be pretty sweet if
I said you can meet Brett Favre or
Justin Timberlake oh man my brother met
Brett Favre a while back and said it was
pretty interesting but I'd have to go
jakey what would you say to him I that's
a true little fangirl how about I try to
set it up where you're a backup dancer
for Justin Timberlake one of his shows I
kill it you kill it yeah but you you
would know what you were doing there
like JT wouldn't have to worry about you
pay attention a little bit take some
notes and okay I'd be I'd be ready I'm
in the Showtime
you know when lights come on I do ready
would you rather do that or win the
Heisman Oh rather be playing football
that's for sure
okay all right Paulie can we make this
happen for Baker that we get a hold of
Justin Timberlake's people do our best
okay man that's how are you going to
wear the bandana when you do that all
right
well we'll work on that no they're only
a small little show but we'll we'll see
what we can do let me see I'll pencil
you in for you got 40 touchdowns eight
interceptions but you lose Mixon you
lose DD man can I go over 40 can you get
me over 40 touchdown passes this year I
can you can't absolutely here's the deal
over 40 I do a full-court press for
Justin Timberlake backup dancer on one
of his shows okay all right fair enough
that's I mean there's got to be high
stakes here all right
now you're excited about the season you
weren't that excited now you are
I guess you're ready hey good to talk to
you we'll talk to you during the season
and of course good luck with your
studies at Oklahoma okay that's a Baker
Mayfield he is
student athlete after all good luck with
your studies there the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience